Hello, everybody
My name is Markiplier and welcome back to bad dream coma, now we're going to go under the hospital. Which was one of the
Middle portions of the last one or was it one of the first ones? I have no idea. Now
I feel like as we go on these chapters are going to get longer and longer
Or maybe they're going to be exactly the same
But I imagine that the puzzles are going to get even more and more interesting. Now what's fascinating about
This is the first time we went through bad dream
The series like it was intricate and it was interesting
But this is in a whole different way like it's vastly improved from the last time that we went through here
And I don't know why I've decided to rifle through all the trash at first. Just wanted to clean up around here. Oh
Hi, "a new person" hey, you got some awful, you got some punchable birds over there "in one piece." Yeah, that's me
Should I ask about what the knocking is?
"That's impressive." Okay good. Thank you
"You seem lost" Ah you know me.. and being lost and what.. "let me explain you the situation"
"We're trapped in this dream"
"For some reason what we can't wake up and nobody knows why."
"Everything here is an illusion, the monsters blood, wounds are not real"
"The only thing real things are pain and fear"
"People are frightened with the vision of endless suffering and disability. Their terrified minds are continually creating new beasts"
Why is it getting darker in here? "We have to find a way to wake up as soon as possible"
"Afterwards it may be too late"
"It'd be best..." oh
oh
"Damn, I gotta go"
"See you later." Okay? Bye puppet man. How you doing bird? I'm not gonna punch you I swear why do you have an ear though?
I'm not gonna punch ya
I wasn't gonna punch ya. Oh, nine-one-one! no that don't work. ok
Well that's there. "out of order" well that's good to know. ohh!!!
Fly! Get out of here fly. I don't mind smashing you
Okay, that works fine! dink dink dink
Okay, all right then. all right what we got
oooo. Hi fly! Get out of here fly. It's really impressive though the most minut little details there.
Oh hi, sir. How you doing? Is your pain real?
What's with this flask on the ground? "Patient cards" "Several fatal wounds paralyzed, traumatized."
"Impossible to care and rehabilitate. Only solution: find a way to wake up."
"Find a way to to wake up"
All right. Sir!
Wake up! It's a dream! You're not actually hurt! Ya loser!
Woah this guy had a lot of days here. An ID card. nothing nothing.
What's this? "This life is fake"  yeah, I know! This guy's injuries are fake. I mean I guess the pain's real.
oh
Ugh, ah hi. What's wrong with a teddy bear? Oh God no, is it okay? Is it gonna live? How you doing?
Alrighty then. You have a very faint heartbeat. There's got to be stuff in these.. oh!
I think that's drinking too much water for my own good. But you know I'll leave it like that. Hi, okay
Why did you do that?
Why did.. who did that and why? What rapscallion kid threw a rock at that window?
Also why is this here? There must be a reason right, huh?
Oh the bugs are coming out. Hi? Who's there?
Hello?
Hello? Oh it is.. dark.
"Strange earthquakes what causes them?" I don't know that other guy seemed to know what... the fuck did I just see?
No, wait, did I see something or was I crazy?  Was
I crazy or did I see something as I was walking out that room?
I feel like I'm crazy, but
I don't know
Woah...what what the hell when did that get different? Oh, it's - oh
Ah, I see, hi okay don't do that.
Alright. Where am I now?
Oh, okay. All right. I didn't know this area was here, but it seems familiar. From the last time I was at this game
Hello. "trash, games, internet" "this computer is infected"
Great. What does that mean? Its Eighteen five.
I don't know what that means. Alrighty, then. Why is this window in this computer all kinds of cracked? Oh
Here we go. I don't know what I just did. What did I just do?
Hi, hi, lady. "Spiders hatched in my kitchen!" Is that a euphemism?
And also it sounds like a personal problem anyway, so I...
Yes spider problem
"Can you deal with them?" Why do I need to deal with them? I'm here looking at the moon
trying to ignore weird doors going off all over the place
oh I don't know what I just
What did I just hit? Oh you gave me a key!
"Please" Okay, lady. I don't... that's not your kitchen
That doors got some real whump to it. Alrighty then
"Disclaimer every action has a reaction! Our minds are capable of creating monsters. We can't leave this dream
So we don't want it to become a nightmare. Don't do anything bad or stupid for the sake of us all"
God, what would happen if I... what would happen if I just started murdering all the birds?
God.. that would be an interesting way to go about this. I may...
"S.O.S" Okay. I don't know how to help you. Maybe something more detailed an sos. That's not the kitchen
The kitchen must be.. yeah, okay. It's over there
Hi, hi, diddly ho neighbor. I don't want to punch that spider
I have a very strong urge to punch these spiders, but I don't want to do that because they're my friends. Wham! Oomp!
bluggh, I got blood on my hands.
I could have put them in the jar.
Nope, I couldn't have put them in the goddamn jars. "Spiders hate me now" that's not my... Oh. God. That goes downhill so fast
that goes downhill so fast. "load autosave" please. oh God, from the beginning!! oh jeez!!
Ah, see there we go now I can jar them. Get in the jar. Get in the jar
Ah get in the jar. There we go. All the spiders have been taken care of now that lady will be happy.
"What's that? You caught the spiders in the jar?"
"Well, they're pretty cute." I know right, and they hate you if you kill em.
"Can I get them?"
"I've always wanted a pet" So long as you treat them nice. Treat them nice, lady.
"Thank you for your help" You're welcome. "Now I can go back to work." Oh
That's good. Boy me? Baby me?
What does that even mean? Theres a sign over there that says, "Boy me."
Don't do that, okay?
All right, let me see, you're in the kitchen. Hi. "Do you need something?" What's this key for?
I don't know, but I guess I'll find out later
Washroom? Oh, the bathroom key! ah ah
This bathroom is less than fun. Oh
Ah, why did I get ewwww! Why did I need to get hair out of the sink??
Tick tock! Oh my mouse has a reflection!
What else we got here? What was in that toi... ohh. Do I want to touch that? I don't want to get blood on my hands.
ugh. "Hair active" ughh ok. Sploshie!
Okay? What you doing?
Can I poke you? Oh, that's probably not a good idea.
I'm not going to poke the random eyes that I see in da bathrooms. Ah lets see what happens.
Oh my God, what did I do? Ah, I made the cyclops!!
The Cyclops!! Oh no!! And look, I got an eye pokey out!!
no, nooo!
Ah God, I can't do that. Like this whole game is just really cool, like the details
I love the details, the details are so cool. They gonna do that? You want some hair in there, all right fine
Sploosher. Great. Ugh what is that.
Well, I got a key. I don't understand
how a key, how a key came out of the toilet. Not like it could flirt. "You need something?"
No, I don't, you keep up with your amazingly amazing place here. What about the key to here? No.
What about the key to the... yeah, that's it.
Hello doctor. Oh
um
Question, are you okay?
Can I have that syringe? No apparently not.
"zzzzzzz. zzzzz. zzzzz."
"zzz top" Okay. "Call me!! 555-279"
Okay, 555-279. Can do. I can call that!
No I can't, but I can take the number off it... I can take the number off of here
Yah. 555, put this back on.
Ah, 555-279! Got ya. Hey... who am I ringing up?
Why am I in here? How did I get in here?
Where am I?
Hello?
ohhhhhhhhhhhhhhhh!
Well why do I have eyes? I don't want eyes. Would you like a shiny bottle cap?
oh!!
Bird's love me???
Bird's like me! I'll take like! Love is, you know, love will come in time, I think. Oh, but you like a shiny bottle cap
Oh, you such a good birb! Oh no, I just realized what I'm doing.
I'm building a bear head. No you can have eyes! Hey! Oh uh
You want ears?
You want hair? Oh! Hi... Hello. Welcome. I thought I was building a bear head, but things got different, puppet man. "Let me help you."
Oh, all right, then. "Much better." Thanks. "Thank you for help."
"sooooooooooo......"
"Tell me, what exactly happened at the graveyard?"
"Have you found any clues?" *smol gasp* Is that the guy from the original game?  Am I not the original guy? "I..."
"I was attacked a few steps from the gate...I haven't found anything useful. I didn't get the chance to look around.
I'm sorry to disappoint you." "It's fine."
"I appreciate that you at least tried." "Few people have here have the courage to do that." "It seems that some tips regarding our
immortality are at the graveyard. Can you check it out for me? I have to look for the nurse."
"We're not looking for anything concrete."
"Just look around for some information."
Okay. "The fastest way to get to the graveyard is by bus. The bus stop is right next to the hospital.
Good luck!" Okay, alright. Go to the graveyard by bus
Okay
alrighty then.
I guess that's all there is then. How do.. how do I get out of here again? What what what? Oh, okay?
Well, I could have left at any time. Oh
"The lying.." Oh hi balloon. I shouldn't.
Shouldn't do nothing about that. I don't want to be mean and have anybody crying on my behalf.
So where's the goddamn bus stop? Oh that looks bad.
So what's that all about? Oh, I got a dead apple. That's nice. Okay. "Don't cross" "Don't go in there"
I don't think I want to anyway. Okay.
Yeesh all righty, then...
Ah good, it's a piece of paper. I like pieces of paper.
Let, let me in! Sanctuary, please. Yeah, it's hard to remember exactly what I've been through already, but here's the bus stop anyway
so that's good. Oh what did I get? "A fish bone." I got a fish bone
Great, oh wait
wait, hang on.
Wait, how do I inspect that? Oh no wait. That's there's a bus ticket
That's the bus stop sign, so I need to find the other pieces of this bus ticket
To be able to get through here, uh. Why would I do that?
Is there a good reason? Boink!  Ha ha ha ha ha ha. I did that and you feel bad. Oh I see.
uh
Okay
Maybe I could cut my way... no I can't cross the line
There's gotta be something here. Wait wait. Oh! I threw that away!
I cleaned up after myself. Hope you all are very proud of me. That was
something that took a lot of guts. I know I'm a pretty awesome dude, but
What did that do exactly? Wait wait wait wait, just had brainwave. Whoa, never mind!
Had the wrong brainwave. Thought I was on to something, realized
I didn't even need to be on that thing that I was on. Okay, there's one more piece of the puzzle
somewhere around here. Oh
Where was that?
Well like okay. I guess I'm good now
Got me a bus ticket, can I, oh, hi, Mr. Bus!🚌
Okay, I did it. Yeah, the birds love me
I think? I'm such a nice guy and the birds love me, so yeah. Anyway
That is chapter
Two. That did take me a bit longer to solve so huh. They may get harder and harder as time goes on
but I'm starting to get, I'm starting to piece this together. And not starting to get it. It's still throwing me for a loop
I love it though. I love the intricacy of it. It's so
interesting! It's so goddamn interesting. So thank you everybody so much for watching, let me know what you thought of it down the comments below
and as always, I will see you in the next video
buhbye!!!!!!